حافه نهايه العالم اسرار الاخدود العظيمه
[موسيقى]
حافه نهايه العالم من اخطر قمم الجبال على
كوكب الارض
مرجانيه واصداف وقواقع وغيرها من الكائنات
انه العمود الفقري الوسط الجزيره العربيه
جبل طويق وحافه نهايه العالم من هنا
وبالقرب من العاصمه السعوديه الرياض تنتهي
سلسله جبال طويق المطله على مجموعه من
الوديان وقد سميت هذه الحافه بنهايه
العالم كونها مشابهه للخدود العظيمه
بمنطقه جراند بولايه اريزونا الامريكيه
جبل طويق يعد من اشهر المرتفعات الجبليه
في وسط شبه الجزيره العربيه
وبعض مكوناته يصل عمرها 160 مليون سنه هذه
التكونات هي مصدر للنفضه ومكان النفطيه في
حقول نفط المنطقه الشرقيه
وتنكشف صخور جبل حافه نهايه العالم
العملاق لمسافه 1200 كيلو متر كما ان جبل
طويق عباره عن سلسله من الجبال تقطعه
اوديه وتغطي اجزاء منها كثبان رمليه ولها
واجهه مقابله الغرب تعرف بنهايه العالم او
المطل ومن ابرز هذه الوديان بحيره ام شقوق
الواقعه امام جبل نهايه العالم و تشهد هذه
الايام هطول امطار جعلت الوادي يمتد طوله
حاليا لاكثر من كيلو متر ونصف كيلو متر
لذا وضعت الجهات المع حدود خرسانيه
للاحتفاظ بها كمحميه طبيعيه من اجل الطيور
المهاجره والازهار البريه المتنوعه
لقد تكونت بحيرات في قلب الصحراء
ورمال قد تتحول لتربه طينيه كانت كثبان
الرمليه الان نشاهدها اقرب ما تكون بحاله
طينيه ونشاهد ايضا كلما حفرنا في الاسفل
نشاهد ما زالت كميه الرمال او كميه الطين
موجوده وهذا بدليل ان كميه الامطار التي
هطلت في هذه المنطقه كباقي مناطق السعوديه
التي تشهد امطار غزيره
حافه العالم تقع حاليا ضد مشروع الجديه
الشهيره الذي اعلن عنه عبر صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه المزمعي الانتهاء منه
قبيل رؤيه المملكه التنمويه التي اطلقها
ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان 2030
وحتى هذه اللحظات كثيرون من مختلف
الجنسيات بداوا التوافد على منطقه حافه
نهايه العالم واعتبروه موقعا مهما
لاستكشاف والمغامره خاصه انه لا يبعد
كثيرا عن العاصمه السعوديه الرياض